neige verglas températures glaciales
l'île de france est marquée par de
nombreuses intempéries depuis deux mois
nous allons vous donner quelques
conseils pour rouler sur la route en
toute sécurité à mes côtés stéphane
pelle et pinto stéphane est ce qu'il ya
des conseils faciles à appliquer quand
on prend le volant
la première chose à faire c'est déjà de
s'assurer d'avoir une voiture en bon
état de marche avec de bons pneus de bon
éclairage qui fonctionne une bonne
visibilité du lave glace pour pouvoir
initier son pare brise et de bons essuie
glaces et après j'ai ensuite qu'ils
souhaitent à l'aise c'est ça pour vous
êtes à l'aise donc enlever ses vêtements
en tout cas son blouson pour pouvoir
être à l'aise ans et les mouvements et
pouvoir gérer facilement les éventuels
problèmes
bon c'est parti on y va allez on y va
on reste concentré sur la route on
regarde loin devant soi
il est important de savoir que le regard
conditionne le geste donc plus on va
regarder loin et mieux on anticipera les
problèmes on regarde toujours l'endroit
où on veut aller
c'est vraiment essentiel on regarde
aussi des voitures qui sont devant nous
de façon à pouvoir anticiper ce qu'elles
vont faire et
on reconduit saint thibault des patins
sa soeur du roi roulettes à l'arrière
donc du coup une petite sensation de
glisse un peu comme sur la neige voyez
il a certains qui l'ont vécu les
problèmes sous la neige mais
malheureusement il y en a certains qui
l'ont vécu donc il faut vraiment
vraiment c'est la chose primordiale
on est vraiment dans un sur un contexte
un peu compliqué il faut gérer un peu
tout ce qui se passe il faut gérer le
comportement inhabituel de la voiture on
de glisse et tout ça c'est vraiment des
difficultés on n'a pas l'habitude
d'apprendre en auto école
voilà donc là je regarde tout de suite à
gauche pour essayer d'emmener ma voiture
là où je veux donc je passe bien
bon c'est vrai que ça va pas vite mais
il faut savoir quelle est la difficulté
des roulettes à l'arrière pas rouler
vite sous la neige
faut pas rêver les visiteurs m eur 15 km
heure ouais on a pu constater
dernièrement que au delà de 20 km heure
on était vraiment à la limite donc vaut
mieux toujours roulé en deçà et
éventuellement accéléré si besoin
plutôt que d'avoir envie de freiner et
de ne pas pouvoir le faire par exemple
un freinage
si je roule là je suis à 10 15 km heure
si je dois freiner
voilà je fais un freinage progressif de
façon à ne pas bloquer les roues alors
merci c'était fait pour tous ses
conseils alors pour synthétiser
il faut être certain que sa voiture soit
dans un bon état de fonctionnement
s'assurer de bien mettre sa ceinture de
sécurité
regarder loin devant soi pour pour
anticiper tout ce qui peut se passer
ne pas utiliser son smartphone poste est
bien concentré et avoir une conduite
douce des freinages doux pour ne pas
bloquer les roues et ne pas glisser
merci beaucoup stéphane et bon courage à
tous ceux qui sont sur la route